hey guys Dr Burke here in this video I'm
going to talk about skin tags and moles
especially around your neck and your
armpits some people have them they don't
know what causes them basically it's a
real tiny little benign tumor um and
it's triggered by a growth factor which
actually is triggered by the hormone
insulin that's why a diabetics or
pre-diabetics start getting these skin
tags around their neck or in their
armpits okay there's other things
that'll happen too but I just want to
kind of give you that that cause effect
relationship and and then of course
insulin is the hormone that regulates
blood sugars okay and what happens is
that um it will actually first cause the
food that you eat to be stored as sugar
that's the first step up to about 400
gram okay so the liver so here here you
you eat some sugar right it it might not
instantly turn into fat but it'll start
to store the sugar as stored sugar or
glycogen in your liver so and then when
it hits 400 gr that's when it starts to
convert to cholesterol in actual fat but
the problem is if you continually eat
sugar or eat too frequently like you're
snacking through the day too much or
grazing at night you're going to raise
insulin to the point where all of a
sudden you develop like a pre-diabetic
state which is insulin resistance and
you start having higher and higher
amounts of insulin an average person
that has insulin resistance has 5 to
seven times more insulin than a normal
person and because insulin is anabolic
it makes things grow just like estrogen
it's a growth factor it starts producing
these items right here so you need to
watch some of my videos on how to lower
insulin to actually completely get rid
of these right here thanks for
watching